[Music]
now we'd like to pray over again and we
know we are people of Prayer so we
stretch our hands and past and present
these are some of their greatest faith
leaders they would love to pray over you
Pastor Jensen's in the start apostle
Maldonado and we love you everybody to
stretch your hands towards the president
before he gets up because we know their
prayer makes a difference let's offer it
Heavenly Father we come to you today and
we thank you for this nation that was
born 1776 we pray in 2020 it would be
born again we pray for your spirit to
move across our nation and we humble
ourselves and we pray we repent the
personal sins the national sins and we
humbly ask you to bless our nation and
to bless our president Donald Trump lord
I thank you that America didn't need a
preacher in the Oval Office it did not
need a professional politician in the
Oval Office but he needed a fighter and
[Applause]
I thank you Lord that he doesn't claim
to be perfect but he is passionate he's
passionate for the to stop the merciless
killing of the unborn he's passionate to
raise people from poverty and six
million have been moved for food stamps
to the dignity of work he is passionate
at home policy our Supreme Court filled
with men and women who will stand for
justice for all and Lord we thank you
for all that you have begun and now that
you've begun it in our nation in the
middle we pray that you would bless
beginnings are wonderful endings are
wonderful but in the middle we need your
help
in the middle of the race the runner
needs a second win in the middle oh god
of battle the reinforcements need to
come in so send your power in your
presence to touch this president show
him who you are
she'll give your love show him the love
of the people and Lord do something so
great in him and in this nation and the
pundits on TV and the news anchors will
be amazed at how great America is
solidly straight in America again in
Jesus name we pray
how much research enhanced over here
please rather than the name of the Lord
Jesus Christ we come before your Lord
we % our president we come together from
all denominations all races together as
the Bible says to pray for those in
authority father let your kingdom come
let you be done on earth as it is in
heaven
father I pray for my president and our
president I pray for you to give him
boldness for him to defy and challenge
science in the world and define and
challenge the enemies in this nation
father I pray for him and I race them up
and pray we come together and Jesus
mighty name we believe we speak in his
body with great healing we pray
restoration through strength and his
mind and his spirit all over his beam
they strengthen with a powerful holy
spirit right now
this place
but the presence to experience the
presence of the Living God we pray for
that resurrection power of Jesus Christ
for him to say jesus is alive father I
pray of all this together we come
together and we pray we stand with him
and what he is doing and probably gives
you the brains we give you the honor and
we give you the praise and honor and we
ask you Father that he can be desirous
to bring Reformation to bring change
into this nation and all the nations of
the earth who will say America is the
greatest nation of the earth father I
thank you you said this time religious
power
I really saw Holy Spirit upon his life
the Holy Spirit's to strengthen him it's
spirit soul and body and father we are
releasing wisdom from heaven
and I declare God that you use them to
change the spiritual atmosphere of this
picture father I'll give you the brace
and I give you the honor and Jesus my
name amen
[Applause]
amen and now is in the spectrum hands
with secure your purpose with secure
calling even victory after victory
victory after victory we declared that
no weapon formed against ammo be able to
prosper and every demonic altered that
has been erected against him will be
torn down
even planted low rise high and he is
seated in heavenly places surrounded
with people of Prayer and let him walk
out the will of God in Jesus name
[Applause]